what I want to do I like night here or
pawn push here actually let's do this my
bishops don't need to move in order to
be developed here so as a follow up
Knight to f6 definitely be looking into
that that's why I threw my F pond out
there first and they're doing similar
let me hop right in there
and what else
hmm
e 6 97 I have to move my queen before I
could Castle kingside and it seems like
that's the most likely way to yeah most
likely going to happen that I castle in
that direction
ah know what
I do this well oh no no no way maybe not
here here oh yeah let me do this it's
very temporary that my night is going to
be hanging out on this square because i
don't like obstructing this central pond
so let's do this right now let's go
mouse let's go
and now what well this seems like a good
start they're ready to castle I didn't
mean to do that I met to just go single
square but I guess man now this night is
going to have a great square I meant to
play d6 stupid Mouse again ah stupid
Mouse well
I so did not want to do that my light
square Bishop is dead lay this almost
every square covered occupied yep it's
perfect it's exactly what you should do
focus right on that square ah Mau slips
mouse lips my lips actually I'm going to
sac that night or am I no not get too
crazy I just think it just here ok take
I'm gonna kick that night away but now I
gotta run away if he's flushed with f3
all right my queen is some more
possibilities now you could see the e
squares and
and what else
hmm
let's go I'm assuming f3 there we go the
night needs to run away f3 and okay i
mean this move can't be played I
definitely need to be moving this pond 1
square I don't want a weakened c5 I go
to I we can see 5 so just to be six
Bishop e7 is the plan and qualms in the
twitch chat yes the mouse the mouse lips
or the mouse the most lips defense yes
the most lips blender this is a good
spot for the Queen and why do I think
I'm gonna do
protect my queen and well I go click
here I guess Bishop here is going to be
played my opponents playing a good game
here good game I really need to get rid
of that night he needs to go this pawn
is unprotected my light square Bishop
needs to weasel around I think right
here just exchange itself off for this
night anything really all right I take
here pon recaptures now I take here
though let's do that and then this trade
queens and get I have to break at this
point right here because that's okay now
i think i am breaking I'm breaking at it
finally it's been overtaken and after
the smoke clears I'm up upon and i'll be
looking to target this guy next whoa I'm
just up they I'm just up now let's back
up
to watch out for deflection type of
moves Bishop takes pawn or Bishop here
but it's not working
ok
let's get this up pond push I just want
to get this King now so I'm okay if
there's this capture pond push hit the
bishop I have a square for my king and
now actually it's the perfect time to do
it since the rook isn't a pin
unprotected oh now that's interesting
I'm going to do it I take their up they
take mine I could have just recaptured
but there were low on time there and
position got to be a bit too much right
there i was out material so let's go
back so all the way back flip that board
and let's see i like this i mean i like
the moves my opponent was making here i
think i really like the coordination you
had here I don't have any suggestions
for these moves that are coming in right
here I again I didn't mean to play d 5
but you know just assuming that I I I
was going to be like yeah that's a good
move um you're following up in the
correct way these are good moves now
it's the oil actually this captured does
not benefit you that's one thing to know
because this guy right here he's if you
do comparison your sepan in my epon this
guy is much better place than this guy
he has more options than him and I mean
if you take I recapture not my queen
could see this night directly and if I
get through to this point I can start
seeing these squares so I think keeping
this tension right here is going to be
better that's one point to make and I
like to have to remove kick my night
away I'm not sure what what the King
move does but maybe just coming
immediately out to h4 would be more to
the point and your weaseling your dark
squared Bishop around
I don't I don't know that that's a
really too big of a problem oh now now
I'm actually breaking that down our
night so you have to you have to do
something here how can you may be
maintained that night well one thing is
to not move your king save yourself a
move with that and try and maybe get in
this Bishop c3 to be for move before
even bringing your queen out in this
direction I think that could be good
right because I'm castled i have three
pieces on this diagonal how about
bishops III to be for something you you
played in the game you played to see
three but then rear out it or reroute it
to this diagonal don't move the King in
the corner go with a more direct bishops
III to be 4i think that's another small
improvement